اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
الاف المفقودين في الزلزال تركيا تضع اليه
للتعرف على الجثث مجهوله الهويه وتبدا
بحصر الاضرار
ارتفاع وتيره المعارك في دنيتك وموسكو
ترفض اتهامات امريكيه بارتكاب جرائم حرب
في اوكرانيا
على وقع التصعيد بين امريكا والصين مسؤول
يتهم بكين بالتجسس على اوكرانيا لصالح
روسيا عبر المسيرات
بلغاريا توقف مهربي بشر بعد العثور على
جثث 18 مهاجرا داخل شاحنه متروكه في قريه
صباح الخير واهلا بكم بعد مرور 13 يوما
على كارثه الزلزال المدمر في كل من تركيا
وسوريا تخطت الحصيله الاخيره للضحايا حاجز
السبعه والاربعين الفا في كلتا الدولتين
مع استمرار الهزات الارتداديه العنيفه ففي
تركيا اعلن رئيس اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه يونس سيزار اعلن ان عدد ضحايا
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب البلاد في الشهر
الجاري تجاوز الاربعين الف اما في سوريا
فقد بلغ عدد الضحايا حتى الان مشاهدينا ما
يقارب
6306 وتسعين موزعين بين مناطق النظام
والمعارضه في البلاد وذلك بحسب المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان ووسط ترقب لقرار
بوقف البحث عن ناجين تكثفه وكالات الاغاثه
الدوليه جهودها فيما اعتبر واحدا من اسوا
كوارث المنطقه وقعت معجزه حقيق في تركيا
مع نجاه ثلاثه اشخاص بينهم طفل من تحت
انقاذ بنايه كناتلي في انطاكيا بولايه
هاتاي جنوب البلاد حيث استطاعوا الصمود
لمئتين وسعه 296 ساعه تحت الركام وقال
وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان صويلح هناك
نحو 82 الف مبنى اما انهارت تماما او
تضررت بشده نتيجه الزلزالين في الولايات
العشر مشيرا الى ان عمليه حصر المباني
المتضرره ستكتمل غدا الاثنين في الاثناء
تنهض تركيا روح الحياه في مدنها المنكوبه
لتبدا بالفعل اعمال التنظيف والتعقيم في
الشوارع المحيطه بالمناطق المتضرره
والمباني وبين اسواق اجتماعيه ومطابخ
متنقله يحاول المنكوبون رويدا رويدا تقبل
واقع مدن الخيام التي قد امتدت تمتد
حياتهم فيها لعام مقبل
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
يستمروا نزوح المتضررين جراء الزلزال من
الولايات المنكوبه في تركيا الى مناطق
اخرى وذلك بحثا عن ماوى ومكان اكثر امانا
شركه الخطوط التركيه قامت حتى الان بنقل
نحو 750 الف شخص من تلك الولايات الى
ولايات اخرى منهم 1500 فقط الى اسطنبول
واشتكى مواطنون من عمليات استغلال من
الشركات لنقل ما بقي من امتعتهم حيث وجدت
في الكارثه او وجدت فرصه لرفع تعريفه
النقل بموازات ذلك تجري حاليا عمليات
التثبيت او التثبت من الجثث المجهوله عبر
فحص الحمض النووي وحول هذا الامر دعا وزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان سويل المواطنين
للتوجه الى مراكز مخصصه في كل الولايه
للحصول على عينه دم لاجراء الفحص وتسهيل
التعرف على اصحاب الجثث المجهوله معنا من
اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي فراس الرضوان اوغلو
اهلا بك معنا سيد ف ايضا عمليه حصر
المباني المتضرره تبدا غدا الاثنين كيف
تجري هذه العمليه تحديدا كيف يتم حصر
البنايات المتضرره
طبعا هو هذا العمل اظن بدا فيه منذ ربما
اليوم الاول مع مزاوله لنقل عمليات
الانقاذ تحت الانقاض الان اظن تتم عمليه
اكثر للتثبت من باقي الابنيه التي ربما لم
تنهار او لم يبدو عليها انها بالصحه او
عفوا بصيغه جيده
وهذا الامر اظن كله الان بدا يسجل ولذلك
هذا انعكس على اسطنبول نفسها التي قرر
رئيس البلديه السيد امام اكرم بايقاف
تقريبا 93 مدرسه من اجل الائمه اعاده
بناءها من جديد وربما 73 مدرسه والباقي
سيعاد ترميمها لانها غير صالحه للزلازل
اذا اظن ان كل الاحصاءات التي تقام في
الجنوب ستسجل من اجل اعاده البناء
والاعمار نجد محاسبه ايضا الذين تسببوا في
هدم الابنيه مثل المقاولون الذين يعني
كانوا سبب الرئيسي في سقوط الامير الحديثه
وهذا اظن انعكس باقي الولايات ايضا باعاده
فحص اغلب الابنيه او سيتم فحص
بحسب معلوماتك هل هي فقط الابنيه التي
تظهر عليها التصدعات ام الابنيه فقط في
منطقه المناطق العشر المنكوبه ام هي جميع
المباني القديمه
لا جميع المباني القديمه تحت الفحص الان
لانها هي سبب الخطر حقيقه اما البرنامج
لنقل الاخرى يتم فحصها عبر اللجنه هندسيه
تفحص اسس واساسات البناء قبل قليل كنت
اشاهد مقطعا في
تلفزيونية عبر الانترنت المهندسون يفحصون
الاسس التي وجد عليها
يكتبون التقرير او حتى يكتبون على البناء
نفسه والاسس او الاعمده التي تحمل البناء
بانها صالحه او غير صالحه طيب ماذا عن
عمليه التحقق من الجثث المجهوله سيد فراس
يعني هل من معلومات حول كيفيه ذلك نعلم
انهم يطلبون الحمض النووي من الاشخاص ولكن
هل هناك اليه معينه واضحه للتحقق من الجثث
طبعا هناك اليه فحص الدم اولا التصوير اذا
كانت الصوره للجثه كانت واضحه وفحص الدم
بعد ذلك
بحث الصور عبر السيستم والنظام الذي موجود
في الداخليه وثالثا فحص الديانه الذي هو
سيكون ربما الاخير ان لم يتم معرفته عبر
الفحص الدم او عبر الصور التي يبث عنها
واخيرا الابلاغات يعني اذا كان هناك
ابلاغات يتم احضار الناس لمشاهده الجثه
كان اقاربهم ام لا والتي لا تعرف الظن هو
الذي يثبت من هو هذا الشخص على ضوءها تقوم
الداخليه بارشفه كل من توفى في ارشيفها
الداخلي واضح طيب سيد فراس تطرقت حضرتك
للاعتقالات التي تحدث للمقاولين
والمخالفين لكود البناء في تركيا والذي
يعني يحم طبعا زلازل والمباني لتقاوم
الزلازل ولكن ماذا عن النصب والاحتيال
الذي نراه من شركات النقل الان وعمليات
استغلال المتضررين نقل امتعتهم ونقلهم من
المناطق المنكوبه الى مناطق اخرى يعني هل
من اجراءات قانونيه متخذه ضد هؤلاء
هنا الصنف الاول الشركات التي تتبع
للحكومه والبلديات اظن كلها مجانيه لكن
الصف الثاني هذا الذي يستغل المشكله ان لا
يوجد قانون يجبر هؤلاء بان ينقلوا مجانا
وهذه ايضا قضيه انسانيه هم لا يلتزمون
بهذا الشيء
سيتم قانونيا صعب ان تحاسب هؤلاء لكن مثلا
قطوط الجو التركيه بعض
البكل هؤلاء مجاني حتى الان في كل النقل
الذي يقوم به اما الخيارات المتاحه امام
المتضررين يعني ان كانوا يواجهون هذا
النصب والاستغلال في ظروف مثل هذه ماذا
يمكن لهم ان يقوموا به
انا اظن هو المشكله عندهم هو الانتظار في
الوقت يعني عندما يتم الاستعانه بالمؤسسات
التي تتبع الحكومه هو مشكلتها الوقت
الانتظار اظن هذا هو الحل الوحيد لديهم
والا انهم سيدفعون تلك المبالغ او يعني
يتم الشكوى لا نعلم هل ستتدخل الحكومه
مثلا وتدفع المبالغ لهذه الشركات او
تجبرهم على خفض التكاليف حتى الان لم تتضح
الصوره حقيقه من قبل الحكومه كيف ستتعامل
مع هؤلاء الشركات الشحن واضح شكرا لك من
اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو
يصل اليوم مشاهدينا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتن الى تركيا في زياره رسميه
لاول مره وسيلتقي بلينك النظيره التركي
مولود اوغلو لمناقشه سبل تقديم المساعده
عقب وقوع الزلزال المدمر والذي تسبب بمقتل
اكثر من سبعه واربعين الف شخص في تركيا
وسوريا وترك اكثر من مليون شخص بلا ماوى
وبعد اسبوعين على هذا الزلزال في تركيا
تتبادل الحكومه والمعارضه الاتهامات وذلك
بالتقصير في مواجهه الازمه ليرشحها البعض
لتكون ورقه مهمه في الانتخابات المرتقبه
في تركيا توصل الاحزاب المعارضه توجيها
الانتقادات لسياسه الحكومه في التعاطي مع
الزلزال لتؤكد بان حجم الكارثه اظهر عجزا
في التعاطي معها فعواقب الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب عده مدن تركيه ستستمر طويلا
وستكون النقطه الابرز على حملات
الانتخابات التشريعيه والرئاسيه التي
ستعقد خلال اشهر وتاخذها حكومه اردوغان
على انها التحدي الاكبر للتخفيف من
تداعيات الزلزال المدمر
وفق تقرير نشرته وكاله بلومبرك قال احد
زعماء المعارضه ان تراكم السلطه السياسيه
بيد اردوغان وضعف الاستجابه السريعه اعاق
جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
وباتت السلطات اقل كفاءه من جديد غير ان
الحكومه ردت ووصف التصريحات الاحزاب
المعارضه بغير اللائقه داعيه في الوقت
نفسه لتظفر كافه الجهود مع تزايد حده
التممل والاستياء في وسط المواطنين مشيره
ان اردوغان اقر ببطء الاستجابه للزلزال
وان تحقيقا سيفتح لمعرفه الاسباب
الزلزال الذي ادى لانهيار الاف البنايات
وتسبب في مقتل العشرات وتشريد الملايين
يمكن ان يكون ورقه مهمه في الانتخابات
ومده للتنفس بين اردوغان واحزاب المعارضه
جو مشحون بالتوترات السياسيه وحتى
الاقتصاديه تنظر بانتخابات صعبه على
الطرفين خصوصا الى توافقت المعارضه ونجحت
بتقديم مرشح مشترك لمنافسه اردوغان
من تركيا الى سلطنه عمان حيث اعلنت
السلطنه عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه بقوه 4.1
درجات على مقياس رختر وذلك وفقا لمركز رصد
الزلازل في جامعه السلطان قابوس فان الهزه
سجلت او سجلت في مدينه الدقم على الساحل
الجنوبي الشرقي للسلطنه وبين المركز ان
الشعور بالهزه كان خفيفا في الدقه وغير
محسوس في المدن الاخرى بما فيها العاصمه
المسقط واشار المرصد الى انه انا اشده او
شده الزلزال تختلف من موقع الى اخر ومن
مبنى الى مبنى اخر وفقا لارتفاعها وطبيعه
التربه نشرتنا مستمره وفيها
قارات اسرائيليه تستهدف كفر سوسه ومدن
اخرى في دمشق وتوقع قتلى وجرحى
احييكم من جديد تتصاعدوا حده المعارك بين
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه حيث قصفت
القوات الاوكرانيه منطقه كيبسكي وبلده
مجاوره في جمهوريه الانفصاليه بسنتي عشره
قذيفه مدفعيه مع الساعات الاولى من صباح
اليوم وذلك وفق مكتب مراقبه وتنسيق
القضايا المتعلقه بجرائم الحرب في
اوكرانيا من جانبه دمر الجيش الروسي معقلا
للقوات الاوكرانيه في لوغونس شرقي
اوكرانيا بصاروخين حراريين وذلك وفقا
لتقارير اعلاميه
[موسيقى]
معنا من دونك مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
اهلا بك معنا رائد اذا التطورات العسكريه
على الارض والقصف يحتدم خصوصا في المثلث
الساخن بين خارقين
انقل لنا الجديد لديك على ارض المعركه
فاطمه بالفعل يعني تطور كبير في المعارك
خاصه في مقاطعه رغم ان الاعمال العسكريه
مستمره على جميع المناطق التي تتواجد فيها
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
وكذلك لكن دانياس لا اعلم اذا كانت اصوات
ودويه الانفجارات تسمع او لا نحن نبعد
كيلو متر واحد عن احياء
الذي اسلفت بانه استهدف منذ الصباح الباكر
يعني باعداد كبيره من الصواريخ والقذائف
الاوكرانيه ربما ان جانب الاوكراني استانف
قصف مدينه دانياس حيث ان المنطقه باتت
تقصف ونشهد هدوءا في المدينه ويعني بدات
الناس تتخوف قليلا وتعود الى بيوتها يعني
تستعر المعارك مع ضخ الجانب الروسي
للاسلحه
الى مناطق الصراع ومناطق المواجهه على
الخطوط الساخنه بخصوص المنطقه الناريه وهي
المثلث الذي يجمع ما بين مقاطعات خاركب
ودانيتكوالوجانس يشهد كثافه باعداد جنود
الروس وتتقدم القوات الروسيه بعوده الى
المناطق التي انسحبت منها نتحدث عن لمان
وكوبيانس واطراف مقاطعه خاركيف تعود
القوات الروسيه بعد ان تمركزت في اطراف
مقاطعه لوغانس في مدينه كريمنايا تعود
القوات الروسيه بعد وصولها الامدادات
والارتال العسكريه لتسيطر على احدى
البلدات في اطراف مقاطعه
وتتقدم اكثر محاوله دفع الجيش الاوكراني
للانسحاب بالفعل جينيكوفكا تلك البلده
التي اعلن عنها الدفاع
الروسي يوم امس ان هذه البلده هي تعتبر
بلده استراتيجيه وهامه لتقدم القوات
الروسيه في محور كوبيانس كما ان القوات
الروسيه ايضا فاطمه تتقدم في المحور
الشمالي رغم استمرار المعارك في المحور
الجنوبي والشرقي من مدينه باقمت لكن
المحور الشمالي يشهد اسخن المعارك حيث
سيطره القوات الروسيه او قوات فاجنر
تحديدا كما تعلمين على بلده باراسكو يفتى
ثم تقدمت الى مدينه اخرى وسيطرت على
العفوا بلده اخرى وسيطرت على تلك البلده
وتتقدم الى البوابه الشماليه من مدينه
طباخ والقتال يدور على جميع اطراف باخمه
الشماليه والجنوبيه والشرقيه اظن ان
المعارك مستعره على اطراف المدينه دوي
الانفجارات لا يتوقف فاطمه ويعني اسلحه
متطوره مستخدما يعني حديثا من قبل الجيش
الروسي نسمع ذويها باستمرار كما اننا
اصبحنا اصوات سقوط القذائف والصواريخ لا
بد من الحديث ان عام مر على الاعمال
العسكريه منذ نهايه فبراير الماضي ربما
هذا التطور الكبير الذي تشهده هذه الايام
مرتبط باكمال عام كامل من العمليات
العسكريه في المنطقه باكملها شكرا لك من
دونيس كوراس العربيه رائد الاغبر
وكما ذكر مراسلنا ومع قرب مرور عام على
حرب اوكرانيا تصاعدت حده التصريحات
الاخيره للمسؤولين الغربيين ضد روسيا
خصوصا في خلال مؤتمر ميونخ للامن الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماك غون اكد استعداد
بلاده لخوض نزاع طويل الامد مشددا على
رغبته في هزيمه روسيا ولكن من دون سحق على
حد وصفه كما ان الحرب لن تنتهي عسكريا وفق
توقعات ماكغون اما الجانب الامريكي ولاول
مره اتهمت نائبه الرئيس كامله هاريس روسيا
بارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه متوعده محاسبه
موسكو على تلك الجرائم سواء كانوا قاده او
متواطئين في الاثناء حذر وزير الخارجيه
الصين من تقديم اي جهود داعمه لروسيا
المجر مشاهدينا شاركت ايضا في التعليق على
الحرب ولكن من جانب اخر حيث قال رئيس
الوزراء
تنجذب بشكل متزاي الصراع في اوكرانيا
وتضاعف الاوضاع خطوره في الوقت الذي
تتارجح اوروبا على شفا الحرب وفقا قولهم
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مشاهدينا بلانكين
اكد ان بلاده ستواصل التنسيق مع شركائها
من اجل دعم كيف امنيا واقتصاديا وانسانيا
التضامن مع اوكرانيا ودعمها لا يزال اقوى
من اي وقت مضى وهناك تصميم كبير بين جميع
البلدان الممثله هنا تقريبا على مواصله
هذا الدعم وضمان انتصار اوكرانيا وصمودها
في وجه العدوان الروسي
الينا من ميونخ مراسله العربيه راغده
بهنام اهلا بك معنا راغده اذا مؤتمر الامن
في ميونخ في يومه الاخير هل لك ان تجملي
لنا ابرز التصريحات التي خرجت من هذا
المؤتمر
صباح الخير فاطمه يعني الوضع في اوكرانيا
او الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت طاغيه بشكل
كبير على هذا المؤتمر منذ يومه الاول الذي
افتتح اصلا يعني بكلمه من الرئيس
الاوكراني توجه فيها الى القاده المجتمعين
هنا من كيف عبر دائره الفيديو ولكن يوم
امس ايضا يعني كان هناك كلام كثير جدا على
يعني متفرعات ربما هذه الحرب على ما يتعلق
بالصين وبايران ودورهما بدعم روسيا كان
هناك تحذير صدر عن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
تحدثتي عنه قبل قليل للصين من يعني تزويد
روسيا
بمساعده عسكريه وقبله سمعنا ايضا التحذير
نفسه صدر من امين عام النيتو يانس شيطان
قال بانه اذا تخطت الصين هذه هذه يعني هذا
الخط وبدا بتزويد روسيا بالسلاح يعني بانه
هي تورط بشكل مباشر في هذه الحرب كان هناك
ايضا تحضيرات لايران كان هناك بيان صدر عن
مجموعه السبع التي اجتمعت يوم امس على
مستوى وزراء الخارجيه لايران لكي توقف
دعمها العسكري لروسيا وايضا يعني كنت انا
تحدثت مع مصدر دبلوماسي غربي قال بانه
الان المخاوف الاوروبيه او الغربيه بشكل
عام كبيره جدا من هذا الدعم العسكري
المتزايد او العلاقه العسكريه المتزايده
بين ايران وروسيا لانه قال بانه هناك خشيه
من ان تكون روسيا تكافئ ايران يعني لانه
ايران تزودها بطائرات من دون طيار وهناك
خشيه لدى الدول الغربيه بانه روسيا تزودها
بالمقابل باسلحه غير تقليديه وهذا بالطبع
يعني يشكل مخاوف كبيره اضافه الى المخاوف
من برنامجها النووي لذلك بالفعل كانت
الحرب في اوكرانيا وما يتعلق بهذه الحربيه
طاغيه على هذا المؤتمر منذ يومه الاول
واليوم الان هناك جلسه ستبدا يعني بعد
قليل تتعلق بامن اوروبا يشارك فيها مفوض
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف مع مسؤولين من استونيا والسويد
تعلمين بان السويد طلبت الانتماء الى
النيتو ولكن يعني هذا الامر معرقل الان من
تركيا وايضا يعني دائما تعبر عن مخاوف من
من روسيا تفضل شكرا لك من ميونخ مراسله
العربيه راغده بهنام
سفير روسيا مشاهدينا لدى امريكا ان تولي
انطونوب وصفت تهامات واشنطن بتورط بلاده
في جرائم ضد الانسانيه في اوكرانيا
بمحاوله للشيطنه مشيرا الى ان الغرض من
الاتهامات الامريكيه هو تبرير تصرفات
واشنطن لتاجيج الازمه في اوكرانيا ونشرت
سفاره روسيا في امريكا تصريحات السفير على
تيليجرام والتي قال فيها ان امريكا لم
تلتزم بتقديم الاسلحه الدفاعيه فقط
لاوكرانيا مثل ما تحدثت في السابق لكنها
ترسل الانظمه صواريخ بعيده المدى ومدرعات
ثقيله مشير الى صعوبه الوثوق في الغرب
فيما يتعلق بمحاوله التوصل الى تهدئه بعد
هذه التصريحات والتصرفات
من موسكو ينضم الينا
المحلل السياسي اهلا بك معنا سيد اذا يعني
اتهامات امريكيه لروسيا بارتكاب جرائم حرب
وهذه الاتهامات مستمره منذ بدايه الحرب
كيف ترد روسيا عليها
بشكل واضح تماما تستمر النهجه السياسي
ومتابعه
عمل عسكري
بقوات المسلح الروسيه بقوات المجموعه
القوات موجوده حاليا في اوكرانيا
للتواصل الى اهداف المعلنه انا اعتبر ان
اهداف المعلنه لم يتغير لحتى الان هي
الديناسه
ابعاد عناشر نجيه من صوت الاوكرانيه باي
ثمن ممكن نقول وهذا سلطه اوكرانيا حاليا
مرتبطه مع ناصر
عنصريه
واناجيه
غربيه وكذلك
كل
ملامح الخطر للامن القومي الروسي الذي هو
ينشا نتيجه
نشاط الامريكي وانتشار حلف شمال الاطلسي
الى اوكرانيا وانضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف
ولكن نشاط سيد فلاف يتزايد وخصوصا بعد
تصريحات التي خرجت من مؤتمر الامن في
ميونخ باستمرار دعم لاوكرانيا امنيا وايضا
دعم بالاسلحه وما الى ذلك ولكن يبدو ان
روسيا لا تكترث يعني روسيا تستخدم وتستقطب
الاسلحه الحديثه الى ساحه المعركه تستقطب
المزيد من الجنود الروس ويبدو انها تحاول
يعني احراز المكاسب على ارض المعركه
الان مكاسب في المعركه الجاريه لان كل يوم
الان يجري التقدم البطيء ولكن نتيجه هذا
التقدم البطيء مدينه استراتيجيه مخمود
كانت تقريبا اليوم مباشره
ويوم يومين يبقى
حصار سيكون مطلق في داخل الحساب في داخل
المحيط هناك حوالي خمسه الاف جندي
اوكرانيا تبقى هناك تحت
تدمير او استسلام لقوات الروسيه
الاستسلام وهذا يبدو انه ليس خيارا متاحا
سيد
للجانب الروسي سنتناول زاويه اخرى معك بعد
مرور العام قرابه العام على الحرب في
اوكرانيا سنقشها معك بعد قليل ابقى معنا
كرما مش في حرب عمادها الكلمه والصوره
تتحول ميادين المعارك بين الرئيس
الاوكراني
ونظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين من الارض
الى الفضاء الالكتروني
اختار ان يطل من الشاشات الصغيره للهواتف
الذكيه عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي فقد
استطاع ان يجمع حتى اللحظه نحو 17 مليون
متابع على انستجرام واكثر من سبعه ملايين
على تويتر ومع كل حدث يصور مقطعا ويختمه
بعباره المجد لاوكرانيا حتى يدعم شعبه
ويشحد هممهم اما بوتين بدا غير اذى بتلك
المنصات فمن المعروف عنه انه نادرا ما
يستخدم الانترنت ولا توجد صفحات رسميه
خاصه به على مواقع التواصل الالكتروني
وبينما يبذل زيلينسكي قصاره جهده موته
وسطا الجهود وكانه منهم او الجنود تلخص
هذه الصور وضع
الجالس على راس الطاوله لا تنتهي تفصل
بينه وبين جنرالاته امتار وامطار
من موسكو نعود الى فتشيس المحلل السياسي
اذا سيد نكمل حديثنا معك وبعد مرور نحو
عام على هذه الحرب من برايك انتصر اعلاميا
اعلاميا يمكن تفوق
ليست اوكرانيا تفوق اعلام الغربي لان كل
الاعلام الذي نحن نشاهد اليوم في صفحات
الانترنت او وسائل الاعلام الاخرى
منبسط من الدول الغربيه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
صفحات خاصه في فيسبوك تويتر انستجرام
صفحات شخصيه له سيدف لاف
في داخل روسيا اصبح اقوى مما هو عمله
البدايه العمليه عسكريه هذا بلا اي شك
كل الاستفتاءات في داخل عروسيا تدل على ان
النمو السمعه
ويطلبون منه اكثر اكثر الصمود اكثر شجاعا
اكثر حزم
ولذلك روسيا تفهم جيدا ان هذا الصراع صراع
الهجودي
فيبقى روسيا كدوله
سوف يكون هي احد مستعمرات مقسمه بين دول
الغربيه بكل ثروتها الطبيعيه
وصناعيه وزرائيه لذلك انا ان توازن في
الميدان لا يمكن اوكرانيا ان تفوق على
روسيا اطلاقا
بالقوه على الميدان لما شهر حتى
يكمل جيش اوكرانيا بكل انواع السلع ولكن
هذا لا يغير طبيعه الحرب الجاريه نعم اذا
هذه حربوديه كما ذكرت سيد شكرا لك من
موسكو المحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
معنا مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا
بك معنا عبد الجواد اذا اخر التطورات
والتصريحات التي صدرت من روسيا تحديدا عقب
هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر الامن في ميونخ ماذا
رصت من تصريحات
مرحبا فاطمه نعم بالفعل يعني الجميع تابع
ما تحدث عنه انطون لكن يعني موقفه هذا
وتصريحه بتحميل واشنطن مسؤوليه الازمه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هو يعكس طبعا الواقع
الروسي الرسمي ان كان للكرملين او
الخارجيه او الدفاع او غيرها من مجلس
الامن الروسي موسكو ما زالت تحمل واشنطن
المسؤوليه الاولى والاخيره لما يحدث في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من ازمه كبيره من ضغط
على الجانب الاوروبي لتسليم المزيد من
السلاح والدعم للحكومه الاوكرانيه لكن
طبعا هذا الموقف اليوم الذي تتحدث عنه
موسكو ما يقلقها يعني بالشكل الاول
والاخير هو محاوله تسليم كيف طبعا انظمه
يعني صواريخ بعيده المدى او او مقاتلات قد
يكون لها اثر كبير في المعركه وقد تصل
ضرباتها الى مناطق روسيه اما الى شبه
جزيره القرم او الى العمق الروسي لذلك
طبعا منذ فتره تحدث بانه على الغرب وعلى
واشنطن تحديدا
الاستماع من جديد لما تحدث عنه فلاديمير
بوتين خلال تواجده في في المنطقه الجنوبيه
قبل النحو اسبوع من الان بحديث عن ان
موسكو لن تكون مكتوفه الايدي في استخدام
السلاح الحديث والخطر في حال تعرضت
اراضيها لاي ضربات قد تطال العمق الروسي
لذلك طبعا هو تلويح جديد لاستخدام النووي
واستخدام صواريخ يعني قويه وتحمل اوزان
كبيره في حال اتجه الغرب نحو نظام كيف هذا
السلاح المشكله طبعا تزيد بشكل كبير
الواقع الروسي من الداخل يتحدث عنها بشكل
كبير خاصه مع اقتراب الرابع والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري وهو موعد مرور عام على بدء
العمليه العسكريه لذلك طبعا الوضع حتى هذه
اللحظه هو مستقر في المدن لا نلاحظ طبعا
خروج اي نزعات او اي احاديث كبيره تتحدث
عن الوضع لكن هي الازمه كما نلاحظ الذي هي
حديثه الجميع ان كانت بين الناس وان كانت
على مواقع التواصل فاطمه شكرا لك من موسكو
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
اوضح مسؤول امريكيه رفيع المستوى مشاهدينا
ان موسكو استخدمت مسيرات صينيه في حربها
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر جمع معلومات
استخباراتيه من كييف مؤكدا ان روسيا قادره
على رؤيه التكتيكات والتقنيات والاجراءات
بما في ذلك كيفيه استجابه الطائرات من دون
طيار لهجمات الحرب الالكترونيه وذلك بحسب
ما نقلت صحيفه
لا تغذي فقط المجهود الحربي الروسي ولكنها
تسمح ايضا للصين بجمع معلومات استخباراتيه
حاسمه في ساحه المعركه
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان بان
ضربه جويه اسرائيليه استهدفت منطقه كفر
سوسه بقلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق مؤكدا
وقوع خمسه عشر قتيلا على الاقل جراءه تلك
الغارات بينما تحدث جيش النظام السوري عن
سقوط خمسه قتلى بينهم جندي في الهجوم وكما
نرى في الصوره هذا احد المباني المتضرره
جراء تلك الغارات
[موسيقى]
مستمرين معكم بعد الفاصل
كوريا الشماليه تستفز اليابان وتطلق
صاروخا باليستيا عابرا للقارات قباله
سواحلها الغربيه
[موسيقى]
الاف المفقودين في الزلزال تركيا تضع اليه
للتعرف على الجثث مجهوله الهويه وتبدا
بحصر الاضرار
ارتفاع وتيره المعارك في
وموسكو ترفض اتهامات امريكيه بارتكاب
جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
على وقع التصعيد بين امريكا والصين مسؤول
يتهم بكين بالتجسس على اوكرانيا لصالح
روسيا عبر المسيرات
بلغاريا توقف مهربي بشر بعد العثور على
جثث 18 مهاجرا داخل شاحنه متروكه قرب
صوفيا
احييكم من جديد قالت كوريا الشماليه انها
اختبرت صاروخا بالستيا عابرا للقارات وذلك
في البحر قباله الساحل الغربي لليابان بعد
ظهر امس واكدت استعدادها لهجوم مضاد نووي
قاتل ضد القوات المعاديه وقالت وكاله
الانباء الحكوميه مشاهدينا الصاروخ اجتازت
989 كيلومتر خلال 67 دقيقه فقط وبلغ اقصى
ارتفاعا له
578 كيلومتر قبل ان يصيب بدقه منطقه محدده
مسبقا في المياه المفتوحه وقالت كوريا
الشماليه ان تجربتها الاخيره للصواريخ
الباليستيه العابره للقارات تهدف الى
زياده تعزيز قدرتها الهجوميه النوويه ضد
منافسيها ووفقا لوكاله الانباء الكوريه
الشماليه الرسميه فان عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ تمت من دون اشعار مسبق وبامر
مباشر من الرئيس كيم ج في الوقت ذاته
نستمع مباشره مشاهدينا لكلمات الممثل
السامي للاتحاد الاوروبي للشؤون الخارجيه
جوزيف بورال في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
هل هذه المشكله بسرعه الامر يتعلق باسابيع
ولا يمكن حل ذلك من خلال تبني مقاربه
جماعيه لان المشتريات تاتي الى السوق فهي
تاتي في
مؤخره قائمه طويله من الطلبيات علينا
نستخدم ما لدى الدول الاعضاء
وقد قدمت هذه الدول الذخائر بانتظار اعاده
بناء المخزون لديها في المدى القريب نريد
ولدينا الادوات لذلك يجب استخدام هذه
الموارد من اجل توفير الذخائر بسرعه الى
اوكرانيا وعلى المدى المتوسط يجب ان يزيد
قدره صناعه الدفاعيه اكثر فاكثر وهذا لا
يمكن ان يحدث بين عشيه وضحاها
ولدينا ايضا الادوات
لدى وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه التي تسمح لنا
للحصول على المزيد من الذخائر لنا جميعا
ما الى الاولويه الى اوكرانيا لا يجب خلط
الاهداف قصيره المدى والغايات متوسطه
المدى على المدى القريب يجب التركيز على
تقديم المزيد من الذخائر لاوكرانيا هذه
مهمه وزراء الدفاع الذين عليهم هذا القرار
وهناك اجتماع طارئ سوف يعقده في السادس
والسابع من مارس وسوف نقدر ريحه السريع
وتيره تزويد اوكرانيا باذخائر واعتقد اننا
بالعمل المشترك يمكن ان نحقق الهدف
كما يجب علينا ان نقوم بواجبنا المنزلي
الذي هو محدد من قبل البوصله التي تم
تبنيها قبل بدء هذه الحرب
والبوصله تحدد الطريقه التي تسمح حول انها
بتطوير
دورنا الدفاعي في الجو والبحر وعلى الارض
ولدينا خصائص خاصه بكل قطاع من هذه
القطاعات بما في ذلك القطاع سيبراني لاننا
نسينا متطلبات الحروب التقليديه ونركز فقط
على الابعاد التكنولوجيه ان هذه الحرب لم
نكن مستعدين لها وعلينا ان نستعيد قدرتنا
مع مراعاه بان الحرب في المستقبل ستكون
مختلفه
وستتطلب قدرات مختلفه
وعلى صناعاتنا ان تتاقلم مع ذلك ونحن
نحتاج لحوالي عشره شهور حتى يتم شراء
ذخيره من عيار 105 وخمسين مليمتر اي حوالي
عام ونحتاج حوالي ثلاث سنوات لشراء صاروخ
جو وهذا لا يتمشى مع الامور التي نعيشها
اليوم هذا لا يتمشى مع حاله الحرب التي
نعيشها اليوم
وهذا عزز ايضا دور النيتو الذي اضحى جهه
فاعل اكبر لتوفيد الامن لاوروبا ولكن ذلك
يتطلب من الدول الاوروبيه تقاسم الاعباء
الدفاعيه
دعوني انتقل الى السياق الفيوسياسي بسرعه
بالامس الرئيس
ماكرون والمستشار تحدث عن ذلك لا يمكن ان
نفكر بالامن الاوروبي دون ان ننظر الى ما
وراء اوروبا ولا شارك مع حلفائنا وشركائنا
في العالم لاسيما في الجنوب
ونرى كيف ان الخطاب الروسي اضحى اقوى حيث
انه يريد ان يحول المعركه بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا الى حرب بين روسيا والغرب
يجب ان نفضح هذا الخطاب
ويجب ان ننظر الى روسيا على انها قوه
امبرياليه وقد وصفها الرئيس ماكرابي القوه
الامبرياليه الجديده الامر كذلك يجب ان
نسمي الامور بمسمياتها
تريد ان تسير على البلد جار يجب ان نقاتل
او نحارب هذا الخطاب الخاطئ ويجب ان
نتعاون مع شركائنا من اجل الخير المشترك
ومن خلال احترام ميثاق الامم المتحده الذي
يجب ان يتاقلم مع عالم اليوم وهو عالم
يختلف عما كان عليه عام
1945 فان نفوذ السياسه تغير والمشهد تغير
بشكل كامل وعلينا ان نتاقلم مع ذلك وهذه
الحرب
شددت ايضا على مواطئ الضعف لدى شركائنا
فيما يتعلق المتطلبات الاجتماعيه
الاقتصاديه لديهم وهم يخشون باننا سنركز
فقط على اوكرانيا
واننا سنحيد عن مسؤولياتنا في مجالات اخرى
هم يلوموننا ولكن علينا نطمئنهم باننا لن
نقوم بذلك بل اننا سوف نزيد دورنا
ومشاركتنا مع كافه بلدان العالم لان هذه
الحرب قد زادت من التحديات التي يواجهها
العالم ساتعلق الامر باسعار الموارد
والنمو الاقتصادي وكذلك القلاقل
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه علينا نثبت باننا
سنظل جهه فاعله ناشطه على الساحه
العالميه وكذلك من خلال
مواجهه هذا الشعور بالاستياء العميق في
اوروبا بسبب او الاعتبارات استعماريه
او في امريكا اللاتينيه وشعور
بالدور الامبريالي بسبب دعم الديكتاتوريات
والشعوب لديها الذاكره قويه علينا نقوم
بدور اكثر نشاطا لنثبت باننا نقاوم وندافع
عن قيم عالميه عندما تعرضت اوكرانيا للغزو
ولكن نحن نعمل ايضا على الصعيد الجي
وسياسيكا جهه تقدم وتوفر الامن وكذلك
تدافع عن ميثاق ومبادئ الامم المتحده
بطريقه شامله ومتسخه هذا هو التحدي الاكبر
الذي نواجهه اذا على المدى القصير الذخائر
بسرعه وعلى المدى المتوسط زياد القدرات
الصناعات الدفاعيه ومن الان وعلى المدى
البعيد ان ننظر الى شركائنا في الجنوب
لجعلهم يشاركون
في في
الشؤون العالم والتصدي للحرب في اوكرانيا
شكرا لكم كنا نستمع معكم مشاهدينا لكلمه
للممثله السامي للاتحاد الاوروبي للشؤون
الخارجيه جوزيف
على اهميه استمرار الدعم لاوكرانيا من
ناحيه الذخائر والاسلحه والامن كذلك وبان
دور الناتو مهم جدا في تعزيز امن اوروبا
هذا الحديث سمعناه على طوال ايام مؤتمر
الامن في ميونخ
ماساه انسانيه استثنائيه هكذا عبر عنها
المسؤولون البلغاريون بعد العثور على جثث
ثمانيه عشر مهاجرا لقوا حتفهم اختناقا
داخل شاحنه متروكه في قريه قربا صوفيا
تدعى وتبعد حوالي عشرين كيلو مترا من
العاصمه بدورها اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
البلغاريه اعلنت ايقاف سبعه مشتبه بهم في
قضيه الشاحنه فيما اكدت مصادر حكوميه
الامساك برئيس عصابه التهريب واوضحت
النيابه ان جميع المتهمين يواجهون عقوبه
السجن حتى 15 عاما بتهم الاتجار بالبشر
وبحسب العناصر الاولى للتحقيق كانت
الشاحنه تقل في شكل غير قانوني 52 شخص
اختبئوا تحت روزا من الخشب معظمهم مهاجرون
افغان اتوا من تركيا ليهربوا ربما من موت
وشيك الى موت محتم
في نيوزيلندا اعلنت السلطات عن ارتفاع عدد
قتلى اعصار غابرييل الى 11 شخصا وفقدان
اكثر من 5000 شخص بعد اسبوع من اجتياح
الاعصار للجزيره الشماليه في البلاد والذي
تسبب ايضا بانقطاع الكهرباء على نحو 62
الف منزل وقدمت السلطات الطوارئ والجيش
وامدادات حيويه من طائرات هليكوبتر الى
بلدات تقطعت بها السبل منذ وقوع الاعصار
[موسيقى]
في الختام نذكر دوما بالعناوين
الاف المفقودين في الزلزال تركيا تضع اليه
للتعرف على الجثث مجهوله الهويه وتبدا
بحصر الاضرار
ارتفاع وتيره المعارك في دونيت كولوغانسك
وموسكو ترفض اتهامات امريكيه بارتكاب
جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
على وقع التصعيد بين امريكا والصين مسؤول
يتهم بكين بالتجسس على اوكرانيا لصالح
روسيا عبر المسيرات
وبلغاريا توقف مهربي بشر بعد العثور على
جثث داخل شاحنه متروكه في قريه قرب صوفيا
في امان الله